Frozen on the outside liquid beverage on the inside very very refreshing hey, what's up guys welcome back
I got a very cool experiment for you today. You might remember a couple of weeks ago
I was hanging out in La with my friend Logan Paul, and we tried taking flat Dr.
Pepper putting in a balloon and soaked it in liquid nitrogen
And the effect was amazing
We ended up creating something was kind of like an icy coconut that had a hard I see shell on the outside
But when you crack it open had a chilled beverage on the inside, so I thought for this video today
Why don't we recreate that experiment but using actual coke that way we end up with a coconut see what I did there?
Now one thing that logan, and I noticed when we were doing this experiment
Originally is that your soda needs to be flat you need to get all the carbonation out of it otherwise it builds pressure and builds
Weird little formations all over your balloon. So the first step in this experiment is to take our soda and shake it up
Quick update guys our soda is absolutely flat I poured it into a large pot
Then I use a mixing meter to mix it around to all the bubbles are gone
Then I use the funnel to pour it back into the bottle and this is what we've got
You can see we shake it up now
hardly any reaction at all
This is about as flat as our soda can possibly get which is great because now you transfer it to our blimp
I think for this experiment. I'm going to use for
This process is going to be pretty simple. We're just going to take the balloon
we're going to just loop it over the mouth of the bottle and we're going to carefully turn it upside down and squeeze it until
The balloon fills up to about the size of a coconut
Then we're just going to disconnect the neck tie it off and slowly dunk it into the nitrogen
So this is where we get to start experimenting a little bit with how much time it takes to get the best results
How much time would need to sit in the liquid nitrogen to make the perfect?
coconut you can put your answers in the comments below, so
I got my stopwatch ready our liquid nitrogen is ready to go, so I'm just going to hit start and make you dumb
Loulou so apparently too much nitrogen in there
I can't dunk it down hauled away, and the balloon is like flapping against the sides because it's all trying to base out
I think the balloon is actually
Freezing on the bottom and plugging off the soft area look at that. It's going crazy I
think it's happening as the balloon is actually too wide it's like trapping the gas and so then the gas is like coming out and
The balloons falling down it's building up pressure and coming out and falling down and repeating. It's like the bottom of that's freezing
But I can't push it down far enough to get the rest
Look at that if I push it down the balloon. Just like expands
That's crazy
Okay, so it's been a little bit over a minute
I think only the bottom of this is freezing the tops not freezing at all because I think we made the balloon too big
So we have to do it again, but this time it can be wound a little bit smaller
So apparently you can actually squish the liquid around and kind of like
Reshape the balloon into the shape that you want make it look a bit nicer
So I think I'm going to go with that shape there a nice round bottom look at the top
That's good enough of a coconut for me. Let's mix it up
We have contact
I'm just gonna let that go. I don't know how I'm gonna get that out yet
Update our nitrogen is bubbling away. I'm going to give this about 45 seconds and then pull it out
We're coming up in 25 seconds now because we just want that outer layer frozen we want the inside as liquid as possible
Let's see how thick 45 seconds gets it
All right, there's 45 seconds there now the trick is to try and get this out
There we go
Oh, you know what I can already feel this isn't quite as solid as I want it to be like it's kind of chunky
But it's not quite frozen yet, so it's going to need a little more time. Let's go in for another minute
Go ahead and push that out
There we go that's looking a little more frozen by the way
This is very cold
But if I danced it around on my fingertips I can actually hold on to it either freezing
Now the balloon is actually frozen to the coke right now. So I got a pan of warm water
We're just going to dip that around rotate the balloon a little bit
And then we should be able to slip the balloon and peel it right off
Yeah, that loosens the balloon up just enough. It should be able to cut it off
Not really the best knife will be doing that way
There we go
That's what we got guys and just get one more bath, and we rinse in warm water here, and there is our coconut
yeah, that's kind of interesting isn't it so you can definitely see the entire outside of this little ball has frozen solid but just like
A real coconut this actually still has liquid inside
So we're to chip away at the shell we could stick in a straw and drink up the liquid inside
Now guys I want to take just a second and give credit where Credit's to my friend, nighthawk
And light is the one who inspired this idea when he tried using dry ice and alcohol to achieve a very similar effect
I love that
We did this with liquid nitrogen
And I loved it it comes out so clean and perfect the liquids
100% drinkable the Shell is 100% Edible and who wouldn't want a liquid nitrogen chilled Soda. This is really cool. All right
So we've seen it about 45 seconds is not enough time two and a half minutes seems to be about perfect
But we broke it up into three different segments for this third experiment
I'm going to try two and a half minutes solid with one fresh red balloon
All right here we go for two and a half minutes start
We're just going to throw that right in and let it go crazy
Boom there's two and a half minutes. Let's go ahead and take that out. Oh
Kind of frozen to the bottom there. Oh
No look at this so the part that was actually touching the thermos didn't really freeze
You must have kept it inflated everything else looks great. We're gonna have to put that down and freeze that a little bit there
Something to consider it. I didn't realize I
Know that might actually work on our favorite though because we might not actually have the real hole
Just remove the balloon and stick in the straw
Look at that
And of course this doesn't just work on coke you can use it on other sodas as well
Well that accelerated quickly
whoa
All right there. We have the guys. There's two and a half minutes
You can see even with the rotating we did get a little deformity up here, or it doesn't seem like it's completely solidified
But that's okay. Go ahead and take the balloon off
It's actually so cold that the layer of water is freezing on the top edge ice I'm going to pull the balloon and off
all the ice breaks off
So check this out guys. We got our little ball of frozen soda here, and if you look straight on it
It actually does resemble a coconut those little chunks broke off on the bottom and give it the little coconut eyes
We flip it around
It looks just like the bottom of a coconut
And that was made from root beer so theoretically if we crack the shell of this
It'll be very similar to a coconut itself. We can stick a straw down inside and drink up the chilled beverage
Let's go ahead and crack it open right here
Go ahead and chip away at the top right here and see we got
Clout that one does pretty deep
Might have had that one in a little bit too long might work better with the straw and stick that down inside
That's good. I think I froze that one a little bit too long
It was like three minutes
And you can see the shell is quite a bit thicker now to that
It almost froze all the way through it looks like a really delicate balance here
So guys this one
I just let run for a minute and a half which is substantially less time than we've done before
But this time I suspended it in the middle of the nitrogen using a fork so that way it didn't touch the walls at all
You can see there's still a small deformity here
But the rest of it feels pretty solid let's go ahead and open this one up and see how that turned out. Oh
Yeah, that's looking good beautiful for that little deformity there. That's kind of funny
Let’s knock that right off, sweet
So guys check it out. This is the best one. We've got so far
I made this out of root beer
And I think we figured out the secret sauce here you put it in the balloon
And you suspend it into the thermos in the center without letting it touch the sides let it run for one minute and 30 seconds
And you end up with something that looks like this the thing
I love about this idea is you've got a nice chilled beverage
It's going to stay very very cold
But it's not going to dilute because it's the actual soda itself keeping it cold
Frozen on the outside Liquid beverage on the inside very very refreshing
And of course if you prefer to have your soda fizzy you can dump out the stuff already in there and pour yourself a fresh batch
All right next up Fanta
All right, orange just came out. This was 1 minute and 30 seconds exactly which apparently for this one was a little bit premature
You can see most of the shell was frozen, but this little bit here on the end was not
This is still pretty cool because we can actually remove the top and it looks like a cracked coconut and you can literally drink out
of it like a glass if you want the thing to be absolutely frozen
I think we're looking for somewhere between a minute and a half to two minutes. The orange is nice and the shell
completely edible
So there you have a guys that's how to use some liquid nitrogen and some soda to make yourself an icy cold
Coconut beverage which you can fully enjoy because it's technically food grade and you can eat the shell as well
Thanks so much for joining us for this experiment. We'll be looking for you the next one. Talk to you then
Let's see what we got
Well, I just like literally exploded in my face look at this
Apparently there was still some carbonation in there or something we got some weird-looking little blemish there
So look it's refillable as well
That's Fancy. Oh Dang
Wow, look at this okay?
So this is unexpected just look down inside our liquid nitrogen container and look what has four
It almost looks like the frost froze to the static electricity coming off of it that
looks crazy
Hey guys, I want to jump back in for just a second to invite you to come follow me on Instagram
I've got a very active page where I post daily pictures and stories of behind the scenes and every day is an adventure
Just take five seconds right now to click the link in the description to come follow me on Instagram at the king of random
I'll see you there